und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und christian sievers
guten abend hinein es ist der tag an dem
bei der hauptstadt politik hektisch
geblättert wird in der verfassung in
gesetzestexten und partei satzungen um
eine frage zu klären die auch die
deutschen insgesamt umtreibt es ist die
machtfrage
und sie ist sehr gut geworden seit die
spd basis für ein neues 2 gespann an der
spitze gestimmt hat das alles umwerfen
könnte was bisher gilt und bisher schon
ziemlich wackelig war kommt mit dem spd
parteitag ende der woche auch das ende
der großen koalition und was käme dann
welche optionen hat angela merkel noch
und was sagen die anderen parteien quo
vadis bundesregierung antworten von
christiane hübscher diese zwei haben das
zeug dazu die regierung zu springen weil
sie mit einer anti drogen kampagne spd
chefs wurden und jetzt ihre partei in
nachverhandlungen mit der union zwingen
wollen koalitionsbruch ist das gespenst
das plötzlich wieder im raum steht kein
mensch möchte aus dem fenster springen
und sozusagen flüchten aus der
regierungsverantwortung aber ein
einfaches weiter-so kann es auch nicht
geben das haben wir uns die mitglieder
mit ihrem wurden glaube ich sehr
deutlich zum ausdruck gebracht es wird
keinen neuen koalitionsvertrag auch
keine neue verhandlungen geben
das wird nicht funktionieren die spd
muss selbst wieder auf die beine kommen
und kann das nicht hier in der regierung
machen und opposition spielen
es ist ein schier unlösbares dilemma
entweder enttäuscht die neue spd-spitze
gleich all die mitglieder wieder die sie
gerade erst gewählt haben oder die union
gibt den spd forderungen nach nicht mit
uns bekräftigt die cdu chefin in den ard
tagesthemen
die csu hat ihren vorsitz mittlerweile
einmal gewechselt die cdu hat das getan
ohne dass diese beiden parteien jemals
den koalitionsvertrag infrage gestellt
haben wie sie auch jetzt keine
notwendigkeit dafür
wer ist schuldig am ende einer regierung
das möchte niemand sei insofern kommt es
auf kommunikative klugheit an es so
darzustellen dass man entweder keine
andere chance hatte oder dass die
perspektive
nicht mehr bestand das kommunikative
umfeld wird entscheidend sein wie am
ende wen fall ist steigt die spd
wirklich aus käme der bundespräsident
wieder ins spiel
er könnte kanzlerin merkel um einen
zweiten jamaika versucht bitten der der
damals davonlief signalisiert schon
interesse
wir sind immer für eine
regierungsbeteiligung offen aber die
inhalte müssen stimmen
vor zwei jahren hat frau merkel uns
nichts angeboten was für das land gut
und für uns attraktiv gewesen wäre wenn
erst jetzt anders ist neues spiel neues
glück sozusagen für die grünen aber wäre
jamaika heute wenig attraktiv aufgrund
ihres umfragehochs machen sie sich
hoffnung auf mehr
wenn es nächste woche an das ist klar
dann gehen wir auch zu gesprächen aber
die lage ist zwei jahre später nach der
letzten bundestagswahl eine komplett
andere als sie vor zwei jahren gewesen
ist aus unserer sicht hätte dann der
souverän wieder das wort neuwahlen aber
fürchten alle anderen parteien im moment
dann vielleicht doch lieber eine
minderheitsregierung
alle spd minister würden durch unions
politiker oder experten ersetzt für
jedes vorhaben müsste sich die kanzlerin
neue mehrheiten suchen was helfen würde
der haushalt für das nächste jahr ist
schon beschlossen
jede regierung im moment kann also bis
zum 31 12 2020 problemlos mit haushalt
regieren
das sehe deshalb keine notwendigkeit für
vorzeitige neuwahl
neuwahlen würden alle aktuellen
gesetzesvorhaben gefährden von
grundrente bis klimaschutz aber
ausgeschlossen ist auch dieses szenario
natürlich nicht es lohnt sich das genau
zu beobachten wir werden das tun wenn
man sich anguckt was deutschlands
landwirtschaft in den vergangenen
jahrzehnten durch macht dann kann einem
schwindlig werden immer weniger bauern
ernähren immer mehr menschen böden
echten artensterben das grundwasser
kippt und die bauern selbst leiden auch
und protestieren in massen und in
traktoren bei der regierung
erstes ergebnis es gibt heute einen
gipfel
die kanzlerin und vertreter von 40
landwirtschaftlichen verbänden neue wege
dringend gesucht für die zukunft einer
branche von der wir alle ganz
unmittelbar leben nicht mit am tisch
sitzt einer der teil des problems ist
und idealerweise eben auch teil der
lösung sein könnte
wer das ist gucken sie in den spiegel
da guckt er sie an der deutsche
verbraucher kaum ein land in europa gibt
so wenig geld für lebensmittel aus wie
wir hier das kilo schweinebraten 499
immer mehr immer besser bitte schön aber
gleichzeitig auch immer billiger dass
das zum verhängnis wird dafür muss man
kein agrarexperte seien die bauern
diesen spagat erleben zwischen
knallharter kalkulation und
verantwortung für die umwelt schildert
barbara lueg jetzt heute morgen um 6 im
oberbayerischen seeshaupt die
melkmaschine saugt in steter taktung
milch aus dem prallen familie heute
bewirtschaftet ihren konventionellen
betrieb in vierter generation
gebannt verfolgen sie seit wochen die
debatte valentin holz selbst will weder
alles schlucken noch ständig jammern
denn der betrieb ernährt die familie
immerhin wir haben das glück noch dass
die münchner einige morgen stabiles
liebe werden sorgen würde das kann man
immerhin schreibt mir aber das ist der
ort kann natürlich im augenblick sohn
florian will den hof in ein paar jahren
übernehmen
seine schwester studiert agrarsystem
wissenschaften
beide sind mit der landwirtschaft und
den tieren eng verwoben und blicken sehr
genau auf die geplanten hohen auflagen
in sachen umwelt und insektenschutz und
die schärferen dünne regeln sie selbst
düngen ausschließlich mit gülle ihrer
tür so geht die rechnung auf bislang
wenn wirklich eine reduzierung der
düngung noch mal dazu kommt dann
bedeutet das entweder zusätzliche
flächenerwerb oder reduzierung von
tierbeständen um diese vorgaben
einhalten zu können
mehr mitsprache für weitere auflagen
fordert valentin holz der nicht nur von
seinen milchkühen lebt sondern auch von
knapp 70 hektar acker und grünland
diesen boden muss er effizient
bewirtschaften und konkurrenzfähig zu
sein und dabei stehen die großen fragen
immer im raum wie formen wir unsere
landschaften was essen wir künftig und
wie schützen wir unsere lebensgrundlagen
ökologisch sinnvoll
ohne dass immer mehr kleinere und
mittlere landwirtschaftsbetriebe an zu
hohen auflagen scheitern und aufgeben
müssen
die gewinnmargen für landwirtschaftliche
produkte sind in den vergangenen jahren
gesunken das heißt es wurde immer mehr
fläche beziehungsweise immer größere
tierbestände nötig um noch von der
landwirtschaft leben zu können die ganze
landwirtschaft befindet sich aktuell in
einem großen umbruch den vor allem viele
kleine betriebe nicht überleben werden
um gerade diese zu stärken appellieren
landwirte valentin haus mit inbrunst an
uns alle uns den konsumenten der für
qualität tiefer in die tasche greifen
soll
einkaufen bürger billig was sie alle
ordner einkaufen oder billig aber
fordernd ude
noch teurer war das funktioniert nicht
umdenken muss auch die nächste
generation die welt dreht sich weiter
doch florian glaubt fest an die zukunft
einer landwirtschaft in deutschland die
beides schafft die natur zu schützen und
wirtschaftlich zu sein
das viel zu tun für uns alle die wir uns
bei arztbesuchen und urlaubszielen vorab
informieren und noch viel umfassender
die frage stellen könnten wie entsteht
das was wir essen eine frage auch an uns
selbst so wir bleiben noch bei der
deutschen politik und dem zunehmend
komplizierteren geschäft
regierungsbildung gundula in thüringen
wollen linke spd und grüne das risiko
einer minderheitsregierung ein gehen das
bekräftigten die spitzen der parteien
bei ihrem vierten treffen seit der
landtagswahl ende oktober der bisherigen
rot rot grünen koalition fehlen vier
stimmen für eine mehrheit sie ist damit
auf die unterstützung von cdu oder fdp
angewiesen die eine duldung kritisch
sehen allerdings will keine der
fraktionen mit der afg zusammenarbeiten
die mit über 23 prozent zweitstärkste
kraft wurde
der landtag von sachsen anhalt hat fast
zwei monate nach dem terroranschlag in
halle mit der politischen aufarbeitung
begonnen
in einem untersuchungsausschuss soll auf
antrag der fdp fraktion unter anderem
der polizeieinsatz am tag der tat
untersucht werden am 9 oktober dem
höchsten jüdischen feiertag war keine
polizei an der synagoge die dort
versammelte jüdische gemeinde war ziel
eines schwer bewaffneten
rechtsextremisten
er scheiterte an der tür und erschoss
daraufhin wahllos zwei menschen
familienministerin gefallen will mit
einem nationalen rat sexuelle gewalt an
kindern und jugendlichen effektiver
bekämpfen
auf der ersten sitzung erklärte der
missbrauchsbeauftragte der regierung
röhrig das ausmaß des missbrauchs dürfe
nicht länger hingenommen werden in
deutschland werden im schnitt täglich 40
kinder sexuell missbraucht
wissenschaftler jugendverbände und
vertreter aus sport und kirchen sollen
schutz und hilfsmechanismen erarbeiten
verteidigungsministerin kramp
karrenbauer hat zum auftakt ihres
truppenbesuchs in afghanistan einen
langen atem für den deutschen einsatz
dort gefordert in masar i scharif
erklärte die ministerin
die arbeit in afghanen
dann sei noch nicht beendet die nato
mission dort dauert nun schon 18 jahre
etwa 1300 bundeswehrsoldaten bilden
afghanische sicherheitskräfte aus und
beraten sie us-präsident trump setzt in
der ukraine affäre weiter auf wolke
eines amtsenthebungsverfahrens weder er
noch seine anwälte würden am mittwoch an
einer anhörung des justizausschusses
teilnehmen erklärte traums
rechtsberatern es sei unklar ob trump
ein faires verfahren gewährt werden
unterdessen hat der ukrainische
präsident zealand ski direkte absprachen
mit trump zu ermittlungen gegen dessen
rivalen joe biden erneut bestritten
in mehreren interviews betonte er die
ukraine befindet sich im krieg es gehe
nicht um ein quid pro quo also um
gegenleistungen
im süden frankreichs hat es innerhalb
einer woche bereits zum zweiten mal
schwere unwetter gegeben
die behörden haben bislang sechs
todesopfer registriert
schwere regenfälle trafen vor allem die
côte d'azur in der region mussten
rettungskräfte immer wieder ausdrücken
dabei kamen auch drei helfer ums leben
die vergangene nacht mit ihrem
hubschrauber bei einem einsatz
abstürzten
heute blieben viele schulen geschlossen
der bahnverkehr war unterbrochen
straßen wurden gesperrt
europa hat sich heute ein großes ziel
gesetzt bis mitte des jahrhunderts der
erste klimaneutrale kontinent werden
also unseren leidenden planeten ab dann
nicht weiter zu schwächen
einen fonds von einer billion euro für
den klimaschutz hat
kommissionspräsidentin ursula von der
leyen heute angekündigt das problem es
ist noch lange hin und es ist zunächst
mal ein wort genau scheiden zwischen
hehren worten und echten taten das
müssten sie in madrid ab heute ganz
besonders da sitzen die staaten dieser
welt zusammen bei der nächsten
weltklimakonferenz sie wissen es reicht
nicht was sie sich bislang gegenseitig
versprochen haben sie wissen ihnen läuft
die zeit davon
ein weiter so wie bisher wäre
katastrophal waren der
uno-generalsekretär und kann doch nicht
ausschließen
was am ende auf der erde immer weiter
immer wärmer wird volker angres
berichtet es ist ihr zweiter tag im amt
ursula von der leyen will einen green
deal ein klimaneutrales europa bis 2050
das hieße europa würde dann nicht mehr
zur erderwärmung beitragen nächsten märz
werden wir erstmals ein europäisches
klimagesetz vorlegen um den übergang zur
klimaneutralität unumkehrbar zu machen
darin geht es um die ausweitung des
emissionshandels den ausbau von sauberer
und bezahlbarer energie und das
voranbringen der kreislaufwirtschaft die
kommissionspräsidentin legt sich fest
ein klimaneutrales europa bisher nur
eine strategische vision jetzt aber soll
daraus ein politisches konzept werden
dass die zukunft europas bestimmt
beispiel stahlindustrie stadt koks
wasserstoff als brennstoff für stahl
kochen das kann den co2 ausstoß bis zu
85 prozent herunterbringen
aber die herstellungskosten für den
klima stahl steigen
beispiel erneuerbare energien 80 prozent
muss ihr anteil bis 2050 betragen aber
es sind erhebliche hürden zu überwinden
nicht nur bei uns europaweit muss das
stromnetz massiv um und ausgebaut werden
beispiel mobilität selbst fahrende
elektroautos digital über apps gerufen
und immer pünktlich zur stelle aber das
bedeutet den abschied vom eigenen auto
zumindest in den ballungsräumen
dafür brauchen wir investitionen
investitionen und forschung im bereich
innovation für grüne technologien um das
in gang zu setzen werden wir einen
nachhaltigen europäischen
investitionsplan vorlegen für den wir im
nächsten jahrzehnt eine billion euro
einplanen
ein großes investitionsprogramm und ein
verbindliches klimaschutzgesetz das war
eine prägnante ankündigung was fehlt
allerdings ist das die klimaziele bis
2030 nachgeschärft werden das muss hier
noch angekündigt werden
die klimagipfel damit es glaubwürdig
wird europas neues klima engagement ein
motivierendes signal für die konferenz
denn alle länder müssen ihre
klimaschutzanstrengungen mindestens
verdreifachen international besser
zusammenarbeiten zum beispiel beim
handel mit emissionszertifikaten und pro
jahr 100 milliarden dollar für die vom
klimawandel am stärksten betroffenen
entwicklungsländer bereit stellen
faule kompromisse sind nicht länger
akzeptabel
196 ländern bietet sich hier in madrid
die chance klimaschutz nun endlich klug
zu gestalten
ja die chance wäre da allerdings ist es
so dass dieses müssten sollten hätten
das kennen wir ja nun schon seit jahren
volker guten abend dann schauen wir uns
dieses konstrukt weltklimakonferenz mal
für einen moment genauer an wie
wahrscheinlich ist es denn dass die
staaten jetzt in madrid auch konkret
liefern
da sagen wir mal ist es wirklich die
letzte chance dass es vorangeht wir
müssen kurz zurückblicken 2015 paris das
pariser klimaabkommen erstmals werden ja
alle länder also industrie und
entwicklungsländer verpflichtet etwas
für den klimaschutz zu tun und dafür hat
man ihn fünf jahre zeit gegeben in
dieser ersten fünf jahres frist und die
läuft 2020 aus also jetzt muss man ran
und einfach die fakten auf den tisch
legen denn im nächsten jahr da wird dann
wirklich bilanz gemacht und dann wird
geguckt okay was hat jedes land
geschafft und die wissenschaftler werden
überprüfen
reicht das um das 1,5 grad limit
hinzukriegen
deswegen ist madrid so wichtig und das
schon mal vorzubereiten startrampe aber
ist er nicht schon klar was die
wissenschaftler sagen werden nämlich
dass wir es nicht hinbekommen
ja aber ist das der grund gar nichts
mehr zu tun ja das wird so sein
klimawandel geht weiter selbst wenn wir
heute alles auf null brächten die
treibhausgase bis das klima sich wieder
ausgependelt hat 60 70 jahre sagen die
wissenschaftler dauert das also wir
werden mit weiterer erderwärmung rechnen
müssen
trotzdem müssen wir 196 länder ja unter
einen hut kriegen
die haben alle sehr sehr
unterschiedliche interessen letztendlich
beispiel entwicklungsländer geht es
immer um die dollars ums geld man muss
hilfe anbieten und jetzt dafür sorgen
dass die investitionen kommen dass die
maßnahmen kommen denn die schäden
hinterher werden wesentlich teurere hat
denn so eine weltklimakonferenz auch
sanktionsmöglichkeiten
oder geht es am ende tatsächlich darum
eine öffentliche meinung herzustellen
die den druck so hoch macht dass kein
land mehr ausführen kann ja letzteres
ist es gibt keine weltklima polizei die
rom fährt und sagte du hast dich daneben
benommen zwei jahre ins gefängnis das
gibt es nicht es ist der öffentliche
druck und er ist ja in den letzten
wochen und monaten stark gestiegen
freies for future ist ja nur ein
beispiel
und das zweite wird sozusagen der
natürliche druck seien die schäden durch
den klimawandel werden so immens sein
dass sich das eine oder andere land sagt
mein gott hätten wir mal vor 20 jahren
schon angefangen das ist zu spät jetzt
muss es voran gehen und dafür muss man
dritt stehen und dieses signal muss von
der fünfundzwanzigste klimakonferenz
sehr konkret und sehr klar ausgehen und
es ist sinnvoll kann auch kurz über zwei
länder vielleicht als erstes die usa da
wissen wir alle der us präsident scheer
tauss ist aus paris aus dem klima
abkommen ausgestiegen
gibt es einen weg um donald trump herum
und die usa trotzdem ins boot zu holen
na ja der witz des as miel der das genau
einen tag nach der nächsten
präsidentenwahl in den usa das erst
wirksam wird sollte es einen anderen
präsidenten gehen kann er wieder einen
brief an die wand schreiben und sagen
april april ich will lieber drinbleiben
paris abkommen ist möglich ansonsten
sind die usa gespalten ungefähr die
hälfte der amerikanischen bundesstaaten
sind für den klimaschutz das ist
sozusagen die kalifornien fraktionen die
machen sehr sehr viel auch erneuerbare
energien sind da teilweise sogar führen
und die andere hälfte das ist eben das
trump lage und er den wahlkampf
versprochen hey leute es gibt überhaupt
keinen klimawandel wir machen weiterhin
kohle alles wird gut und dazwischen
streitet man sich halt in den usa und
dann noch ein land das vielleicht auch
ein bisschen hoffnung gibt und zwar
überraschenderweise indien ja das hätte
ich auch nicht für möglich gehalten in
den riesen bevölkerungswachstum wird
china demnächst ja überholen und bisher
ein coole land aber die zahlen sagen uns
dass bis 2030 in indien ungefähr 40
prozent erneuerbare energien im
stromnetz sein werden kohlekraftwerke
werden zwar immer noch gebaut aber es
werden deutlich weniger
und das bei einem solchen land wo man
ist einfach so gar nicht für möglich
gehalten hätte
ja es wird auch da mehr emissionen geben
aber das ist echt ein signal der
hoffnung ein kleines wenigstens volker
vielen dank gern
die folgen sind die prognosen natürlich
sind klar die prognose sind deutlich und
verheerend in australien da erleben sie
im moment wie das ist wenn brände wüten
die so gewaltig sind dass sie ihr
eigenes wetter erzeugen wenn es brennt
wo es sonst nie brannte und wenn es gar
nicht aufhört zu brennen fast niemand
zweifelt mehr daran dass das auch ein
resultat des klimawandels ist fast
niemand außer der australischen
regierung und die hat argumente die
wenig mit wissenschaft zu tun haben und
viel mit politik normen odenthal
berichtet saftige wiesen kniehöhe felder
das war einmal
heute fährt mit rendel über staubiges
land die dürre ist brutal und das was
hier vor sich hin kümmert muss seine
farm am laufen halten
die paar hier geben nur noch futter für
die schafe aber wenigstens etwas
wenn du keine tiere hass und nur auf
getreide setzt kannst du es komplett
vergessen es wächst nichts dann machst
du überhaupt kein geld mehr verliert
alles der fluss ist praktisch
ausgetrocknet wasser fehlt an allen
ecken und enden der letzte ergiebige
regen liegt satte drei jahre zurück
alles ist extrem normal gibt es nicht
mehr
wir sind hier an harte zeiten gewöhnt
hatten bürger hatten auch schon
überschwemmungen das habe ich selbst
erlebt
aber diese trockenheit nimmt kein ende
die älteren sagen so schlimm
australien leidet wie kaum zuvor unter
der dürre und unter den buschbränden die
seit wochen wüten sich durch
ausgetrocknete land fressen unaufhaltsam
weil alles brennt wie zunder
für experten eine menschen gemachte
katastrophe
die sache ist eindeutig was sind die
folgen des klimawandels die regierungen
leuten das warum sie setzt voll auf das
geschäft mit kohle und das hindert sie
ganz offensichtlich daran die
zusammenhänge den klimawandel und seine
konsequenzen ans werk kohleabbau kohle
machen australien ist weltgrößter
exporteur einer klimafeindlichen
schmutzigen energie das bringt geld
schafft jobs hat australien gross
gemacht in wahlkämpfen hat dass noch
immer viele überzeugt die argumentation
ist simpel und wacklig australien
verursacht gerade mal 1,3 prozent der
weltweiten co2-emissionen australien ist
kein klimakiller emissionen sind keine
nationale angelegenheit aber dort wo der
großteil der emissionen entsteht dort
sind diejenigen die das klima der welt
in gefahr bringen einsicht gibt es nicht
umkehr erst recht nicht und was würde
das überhaupt helfen jetzt fragen sich
auch matt und joe die farmer für sie ist
klimawandel zwar das problem aber selbst
die umweltfreundlichste politik rechte
doch morgen keinen regen die sorgen
bleiben also werden immer größer das ist
das erste was du denkst wenn du
aufwachst das ist das letzte was du
denkst bevor du versuchst zu schlafen
ohne pause planen nachdenken es
weitergehen soll
wir kriegen das noch einigermaßen hin
aber andere zerbrechen seien finanziell
maintal es ist einfach zu hart
klimawandel australien ist opfer und
antreiber zugleich immerhin ist bewegung
in die debatte gekommen von der hier
viele lange nichts wissen wollten
eine welt manchmal welten voneinander
entfernt wir machen noch mal nachrichten
nochmal gundula die finanzmärkte sind
mit sinkenden kursen in die neue woche
gestartet
wieder ist es der handelsstreit zwischen
den usa und china der die märkte
belastet jetzt hat china sanktionen
gegen die usa verhängten valerie haller
weitere belastungen
ja da kann eine menge zusammen heute
morgen die recht milden sanktionen von
china gegen die usa weil washington ja
die demokratiebewegung in hongkong
unterstützt peking verbietet jetzt
schiffe der us marine in hongkong
anzulegen und will pro demokratische us
organisationen in der metropole
bestrafen politische sanktionen also
keine wirtschaftlichen was donald trump
viel mehr ärgert china bezieht im zuge
des handels streits nun deutlich mehr
soja und mais von brasilien und
argentinien als von den usa
dafür zahlen die beiden jetzt vermutlich
einen hohen preis us strafzölle auf
stahl und aluminium sollen wieder in
kraft treten
der us-präsident begründet den schritt
damit dass brasilien und argentinien
ihre währungen massiv abgewertet hätten
das sei schlecht für amerikanische
landwirte eine fadenscheinige erklärung
finden börsianer
an der börse ging es in der gemengelage
heute steil bergab der dax verliert 2
prozent fällt unter 13.000 punkte krems
entscheidung berührt die deutsche
wirtschaft nicht und dennoch macht sie
anleger nervös der us präsident kann
jederzeit strafzölle erlassen vielleicht
schon bald zumal die eu heute eine
schlappe einstecken musste vor der
welthandelsorganisation dort heißt es
trotz gegenteiliger behauptungen
subventioniere die eu immer noch den
flugzeugbauer airbus die us regierung
reagierte prompt man denke über neue
strafzölle gegen die eu nach und das kam
gerade eben diese nachricht vielen dank
valerie
china und russland haben ein gewaltiges
erdgasprojekt in betrieb genommen und
bauen so ihre energie partnerschaft
weiter aus der betreiber der pipeline
der staatskonzern gazprom öffnete heute
ein ventil so dass erstmals gas über die
grenze in ostsibirien nach china strömte
die beiden präsidenten putin und sie
waren per videokonferenz zugeschaltet
das erdgas aus der region nördlich des
baikalsees soll ab 2025 knapp zehn
prozent des chinesischen verbrauchs
decken
in deutschland gibt es immer mehr wölfe
nach angaben des bundesamtes für
naturschutz ist die zahl der rudel
hierzulande von 77 auf 105 gestiegen
insgesamt sind in deutschland mindestens
275 erwachsene tiere erfasst die meisten
rudel leben in brandenburg gefolgt von
sachsen und niedersachsen einst
ausgerottet breiten sich die wölfe seit
der jahrtausendwende in deutschland
wieder aus weil sie aber auch immer
wieder nutztiere reißen fordern halte
wie umwelt schütze von der politik mehr
hilfe beim herdenschutz so und jetzt
nachhaltig in den montagabend natürlich
kann man große konzerte bestreiten mit
millionenteuren stradivari geigen
man kann auch zum schrotthändler gehen
370 euro hinlegen und alte ölfässer
blech keinen heizungsrohre abstauben um
sie zum klingen zu bringen und wie
claudio armbruster zeigt uns einen
meister der musikalischen wieder
verwertung wer die großen konzerthallen
der welt beschallt
[Musik]
die geschichte beginnt auf dem
schrottplatz in linz christoph sitzen 27
jahre alt und von beruf perkussionist
schlagzeuger ist auf der suche nach
klang der österreichische komponist
georg friedrich haas hat ein konzert für
ihn geschrieben für orchester und
klangwerk und dieses klangwerk soll eben
kein handelsübliches instrument sein
sondern altmetall seit zwei monaten
sammelt er um ein möglichst großes
klangspektrum zusammenzubekommen um auch
melodien spielen zu können
das ist jetzt die ecke mit den spezial
sachen die liebe ich weil das sind immer
wieder ganz ganz unterschiedliche dinge
wie man jetzt einfach hier auch sie
pokale
okay der nicht hier ist 100
bis hin zur klassik
jetzt muss er das ganze schwere zeug
irgendwie abtransportieren und zum
musikinstrument machen
drei wochen später die philharmonie in
luxemburg hier findet am abend die
welturaufführung des konzerts stadt hier
wird der schrott aus linz zur musik
generalprobe
so sieht sie aus die klang wand das
ganze altmetall an schnüren aufgereiht
auch der komponist ist angereist um zu
schauen ob auch alles gut läuft mit
seinem außergewöhnlichen werk georg
friedrich haas wir haben eine frage herr
haas wie kamen sie denn auf diese idee
warum musste es ausgerechnet schrott
sein
das ist nicht schuld das sind wunderbare
klang elemente ich versuche eine musik
zu schreiben die emotional berühren kann
und menschen erreichen kann nicht obwohl
sicher ist sondern welche und dann
endlich das konzert für klangwerk und
orchester
[Musik]
am schluss wechselt er von der klang
wand zu dem normalen trommeln von der
klangsinnlichkeit zur puren energie
[Musik]
doch am anfang war der schrott
ein schlagwerker hoffentlich hatten sie
den fernseher schön laut und falls wir
uns im netz gucken gleich noch mal
wiederholen
am besten mit kopfhörern morgen
übernimmt hier claus kleber an dieser
stelle und jetzt im zdf für serienfans
ein spezielles deutsch-österreichisches
ermittlerduo in den tief verschneiten
alpen heiß erwartet der pass und um
mitternacht endet sich hanna zimmermann
mit hd+ worden
[Musik]
und da bliebe zuschauer in dieser woche
gibt es meist ruhiges herbstwetter in
norddeutschland allerdings wie hier in
hamburg wird es morgen eher trüb sein es
kann auch hier und da ein bisschen
regnen
aber es kommt ja ein hochdruckgebiet zu
uns trotzdem haben wir norddeutschland
ein paar dichtere wolken dieses
hochdruckgebiet wird sich genau über
mitteleuropa morgen legen aber von
nordwesten ziehen halt von der nordsee
immer wieder dichtere wolken über den
nordosten deutschland im süden da wird
die sonne dann zeitweise scheint ja in
den nächsten stunden haben wir noch ein
paar schauer zu erwarten vor allen
dingen am nordrand der mittelgebirge
aber auch teilweise bis zum einkommen
die voran mit schneeregen und schnee und
zusammen mit dem nebel kann das ganze
dann überfrieren in der nacht denn es
wird verbreitet frostig temperaturen
morgen früh minus 1 bis minus 4 grad
über den schnee flächen an den alpen
minus 7 grad nur im nordwesten bleibt es
frostfrei und da haben wir morgen die
höchsten temperaturen meist so was bis
zu acht grad einer nordsee sonst in den
mittelgebirgen sind es etwa null grad es
wird ein trüber tage norddeutschland an
den küsten seien hier und da kann es
auch etwas regnen und räten kräftiger
wer es bis südwestwind dazu die sonne
scheint kaum in norddeutschland er
südlich des mains da kommt sie wieder
raus und da wird es dann auch ziemlich
freundlich werden vor allen dingen
richtung schwarzwald und allgäu scheint
herrlich die sonne teilweise auch an der
donau die aussichten sonnig bis zum
freitag häufig sonnig zumindest aber
dann am freitag wird es von nordwesten
anfangen zu regnen und es wird sehr
windig ich wünsche euch noch einen
schönen abend und machen sie's gut